et la france qui compte donc plus de 48
millions de primo vacciner un chiffre
qui ne cesse de progresser mais qui
n'est pas assez élevé donc pour
envisager une rentrée sereine d'autant
que près de 20 % des plus de 80 ans
reste à protéger un dispositif a été mis
en place aujourd'hui pour les y
encourager les explications de nadège
abderrazak
les seniors étaient les premiers sur la
ligne de départ de la vaccination
aujourd'hui ils sont loin d'avoir tous
franchi l'arrivée quand les sexagénaires
sont 88% avoir reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin ils sont 96 % chez les
septuagénaires la couverture vaccinale
tombe à
84,2 % pour les plus de 80 ans alors
qu'il s'agit de la population la plus
vulnérable face aux colis de 19 dans
cette catégorie d'âge plus de 600000
personnes n'ont toujours pas été
vaccinés ils sont la priorité des
priorités c'est une épidémie qui tue
surtout des non vaccinés
les hôpitaux sont remplis de nombreux
vacciner les décès tous des non vaccinés
au sein de l'union européenne la france
c'est pâle figure l'espagne le portugal
l'irlande le danemark ou encore
l'autriche affiche 100% de vacciner chez
les personnes âgées de plus de 80 ans
97 % au royaume-uni et plus de 96 en
italie et à chypre en france la
proportion de personnes vaccinées chez
les plus de 60 ans est insuffisante de
l'ordre de 85% la france se situe dans
le peloton des pays européens avec une
position plus favorable en ce qui
concerne la vaccination des adolescents
mais plus vulnérables pour la
vaccination des plus de 60 ans la
vaccination des seniors patine mais
pourquoi une des raisons invoquées le
manque de confiance vis-à-vis des
vaccins quel que soit l'âge les gens
gardent leurs convictions il y avait
effectivement des personnes âgées qui
restent réfractaires à la vaccination
l' influence des enfants sur les
décisions des personnes âgées n'est pas
non plus à négliger ils leur font
confiance et certains refusent la
vaccination parce que leurs enfants
leur déconseille voir leur interdisent
l'isolément des personnes âgées pose
aussi question certains n'ont pas
internet d'autres ne peuvent pas se
déplacer les services publics français
ne réussissent pas à identifier les
personnes âgées qui sont aujourd'hui les
plus exclus de la société ce sont les
personnes qui ont de grandes difficultés
de mobilité ou qui connaissent des
troubles cognitifs qui ne sont pas
encore vaccinés il faudrait peut-être
revoir le système de santé et pour cause
le médecin se déplace très peu à
domicile tout comme les pharmaciens
d'ailleurs depuis quelques mois la
caisse nationale d'assurance maladie les
agences régionales de santé et les
collectivités
multiplient les opérations d'aller vers
dispositif qui permet d'aller au contact
et des personnes âgées et précaires
éloigné du système de santé oms vient de
franchir le million de français vaccinés
via nos opérations d'aller vers qu'on
fait pour aller chercher des personnes
qui ne peuvent pas pour différentes
raisons se déplacer jusqu'à la
vaccination c'est un million de
personnes qui probablement ne se serait
pas fait vacciner si on n'avait pas été
les chercher au pied de leurs immeubles
via des associations qui ont l'habitude
de les accompagner ça reste tout de même
loin d'être suffisant pour certains
praticiens il faut évidemment que
l'impulsion viennent de l'état c'est
évident après l'état doit trouver des
relais il faut que les mairies et les
départements utilisent leurs fichiers de
personnes fragiles ou dépendantes pour
vérifier qu'on est complet sur cette
population là je crains que si l'on ne
va pas assez vite avant le mois
d'octobre on est vraiment de gros dégâts
15 % des plus de 80 ans n'ont toujours
pas reçu de premières injections du
vaccin anti qu'ovide a malgré cela la
campagne de la troisième dose s'ouvre ce
mercredi